this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by Skillshare home to
over 20,000 classes that could teach you
a new life skill as world war ii drew to
a close and the race to Berlin reached
its finale
two Soviet armies converged on the Third
Reich capital marshal Georgi Zhukov from
the north and marshal ivan koloff from
the south motivated to beat the
Americans and British to claim Nazi
technology and plunder for themselves
the battle for Berlin raged for 17 days
as the Soviet forces surrounded the city
but the Nazi surrender may have come
sooner if not for one of the largest
defensive structures ever built as the
150th and 170 first Soviet rifle
divisions began advancing across the
Spree River they met the zoo tower
located within the Berlin Zoo
a behemoth structure built as a center
for anti-aircraft operations equipped
with four 12.8 centimeter flak 40
anti-aircraft guns together capable of
firing 96 rounds per minute and with a
group of 20 millimeter and 37 millimeter
anti-aircraft guns on the lower
platforms the zoo Tower was a veritable
Death Castle a death castle with no
glaring design flaw to lead to its
disruption any aircraft that dared
entered ten kilometer range was likely
to meet its end but on this day the zoo
tower turned its attention to the ground
and the approaching Soviet Army began
unleashing powerful and accurate fire
reducing their tanks to smoldering
scraps of metal in short time and
halting their progress the Soviets
ordered the tower to be shelled at range
from their most powerful 203 millimeter
howitzer a purpose-built bunker buster'
but the 100 kilogram rounds had little
effect with two point five meter thick
steel reinforced concrete walls the
tower was practically immune to shell
damage even if a hole could be punched
through with repeated shots the tower
would remain standing with no single
load-bearing structure it would take an
immense explosion to take down these
towers the Soviets instead decided it
was best to circle around the tower
outside its effective range and later
negotiate a surrender the zoo tower was
the first of many anti-aircraft towers
built throughout Nazi cities Berlin had
three pairs of towers forming a
defensive triangle around the city
center and central government the first
pair in
zoo the next in Friedrichshain and the
third in humboldt ein two more parrots
were constructed to protect the vital
port of Hamburg and finally three more
Paris are constructed in Vienna Austria
to form another defensive triangle
around the city centre amazingly many of
these towers remain intact despite
numerous efforts to destroy them stark
reminders for the inhabitants of the
cities of an evil war waged by their
ancestors the towers were ordered to be
built by Hitler after the devastating
and merciless bombing raids of civilian
targets in Berlin in 1940 by the British
RAF furious Hitler demanded top priority
for the project ordering railway and
shipping traffic to be diverted to
satisfy the 1600 tons of material needed
for every day of construction with the
help of forced labour the zoo tower was
completed in just six months and used a
total of 78 thousand tons of gravel
35,000 tons of cement and 92 hundred
tons of steel along with the immense
amount of wood required for the moulds
that formed the shape of the towers to
this day you can still see the outlines
of the planks that formed these molds
each tower complex consisted of a tower
pair an attack tower named the G tower
and a communications tower called the L
tower all communication towers took this
rectangular shape and came equipped with
radio equipment spotlights and their own
anti-aircraft guns and were tasked with
coordinating the attack the attack
towers came in a variety of shapes with
the earlier generation fortresses taking
the square form 42 metres high and 57
meters wide with turrets on each corner
later in the war as supplies became more
scarce the designs took the form of
these 16 sided circular structures fifty
point six metres high and 43 metres in
diameter like this one in a garden park
in Vienna but the attack towers were
capable of firing 8,000 rounds per
minute
they formed a formidable air defense
within their effective range but in
reality these towers had an extremely
unimpressive track record with downing
planes instead they acted primarily as a
deterrent on a bomber that dared stray
into their sights would be more than
likely shot down but instead they mostly
just kept away from these stationary
positions each complex had an effective
range of about 10 kilometers so the
towers formed an important defense for
the strategic positions they Cove
but left much of their cities
unprotected but these towers were much
more than just flak towers they served
as valuable shelters for the civilian
populations each tower had its own
freshwater well and vast stores of food
the towers had their own power
generators with underground supply lines
for fuel and of course massive stories
of ammunition the towers even contain
hospitals with one tower containing a
maternity ward where many Berliners were
born during air raids up to 15,000
civilians could take refuge from the
relentless bombing in the final days of
the war up to three times that number
are reported to have crammed themselves
into these concrete shelves leading to
horrifying conditions with people dying
in the cramped corridors with nowhere to
bury them toilets overflowing and the
hospitals overflowing with injured and
dead patients there are a few visible
signs of the devastation these cities
enjoyed during the Second World War
thanks for the funding of the Marshall
Plan cities were rebuilt brick by brick
removing the scars of the past but these
buildings remain a testament to the
strength of their construction all
valuable materials have been stripped
away from them and multiple attempts
have been made to destroy them but with
the proximity of the surrounding city
and the thick concrete walls the
demolition has proven too costly and
difficult to undertake of the six towers
in Berlin only one remains mostly intact
the zoo tower was destroyed by British
engineers but it didn't go down without
a fight on the first attempt the
engineers packed it with 25 tons of
dynamite when the dust cleared the tower
remained standing the tower finally
collapsed on the third attempt with 35
tons of dynamite and from there the
rubble was broken up and transported
away and the land handed over to the
Berlin Zoo where the hippopotamus park
now resides both of hamburg's attack
towers remain with one being transformed
into a nightclub the other now acting as
a joint energy storage facility the
thick concrete walls provide fantastic
insulation allowing for the inside to be
filled with 2 million litres of water
which is heated with biomethane and
woodchip burners solar panels on the
roof and waste heat from a nearby
factory providing heating for 3,000
homes and electricity for 1,000 all of
Vienna's towers remain but only one has
been fully repurposed as an aquarium
once again taking advantage of the
thermal civility of the interior for
climate control of the tanks while the
walls of the
Miriam have been repurposed as a
climbing wolf the attack tower in
Arenberg Park has been used as a
storehouse for artwork to this attack
tower in ogre and park had one attempted
demolition but it only managed to crack
the roof and collapse one of the
balconies and as a result the tower has
been reinforced with steel wire to
protect the public from a possible
collapse today these towers remain as a
gargantuan reminder of a terrible war
but have been accepted and assimilated
into the urban landscape parks have
formed around them zoos around and
inside them and have even been
repurposed to help towards a more
sustainable future you may have admired
some of the shots in this video and I
recorded all of the footage you saw of
the Austrian flak towers myself while on
a road trip through Germany and Austria
which you can follow by watching my new
vlog series where I visit present-day
locations from world war ii to teach you
about their history i'm the type of
person that never reads instructions
I'd much rather dive in and learned
through trial and error and that has led
to some hilarious shortcomings with my
drone cinematography
I only just recently discovered that I
can adjust the pitch and exposure of the
drones camera in flight with small dials
at the back had I actually gone to the
bother of watching a few tutorials like
this drone videography course in
Skillshare I would have learned this
lesson far sooner these days you can
teach yourself pretty much any skill
online and Skillshare is a fantastic
place to do it with professional and
understandable classes that follow a
clear learning curve you can dive in and
start learning how to do the work you
love a premium membership begins around
$10 a month for unlimited access to all
courses but the first 1,000 people a
sign up with this link will get the
first two months for free so ask
yourself right now what skill have you
been putting off learning or project
have you been dreaming of completing but
you aren't sure if you've the skills to
do it why not start right now and sign
up the skill share using the link below
to get your first two months free you
have nothing to lose on a valuable life
skill to gain as usual thanks for
watching and thank you to all my patreon
supporters if you'd like to see more
from me the links to my Twitter Facebook
discord server subreddit and Instagram
pages are below
[Music]
you